[Musica]
Oh
un'arancia un prodotto della natura con
forma colore e gusto dati per scontato
ha un involucro esterno
compostabile che consente di aprirla
facilmente con le
mani e dunque di poterla consumare come
una merenda da passeggio e anche in
ambienti chiusi visto l'aroma inebriante
che
Sprigiona al suo
interno gli spicchi sono disposti in
modo circolare così da ottimizzare negli
spazi e sono a dimensione di morso ogni
spicchio è suddiviso e rivestito da una
sottile membrana trasparente che
consente di poterli staccare gli uni
dagli altri e portargli alla bocca senza
sporcarsi le mani E questo rende
l'arancia un fattore di
socializzazione questa
analisi così progettuale
dell'arancia la fece un signore negli
anni 60 Un certo Bruno
Munari
Munari analizzò a
posteriori un prodotto della natura in
modo
progettuale e dunque io mi
chiedo è possibile analizzare e
progettare a priori un
cibo è possibile guardare al cibo in
modo
diverso molti di voi magari mi conoscono
perché mi hanno visto in TV oppure
perché mi seguono sui social e sanno
quanto io non abbia mai voluto
nascondere la mia
storia perché Per me il cibo è sempre
stato un elemento simbolico fin da
piccola in famiglia il cibo per me è
espressione a
360° nel lontano 2019 mi sono ammalata
ai disturbi del comportamento
alimentare e solo poco prima di questa
malattia mi sono avvicinata
effettivamente al mondo della cucina in
senso di
cucinare passavo dai dolci al pane alla
panificazione e infine sono approdata al
salato ma in quel
2019-2020 stavo affrontando il mio terzo
anno di studi e mi stavo laureando in
design e da buona designer come sono non
posso che disegnare ogni cosa che dico
oggi con la sinistra perché la destra è
fuori uso
grazie al mio problema al mio alla mia
patologia ho intrapreso un percorso
personale psicologico e questo percorso
mi ha dato la possibilità di iniziare a
vedere alle cose che mi stessero
succedendo intorno da una prospettiva
diversa da un punto di vista diverso
sicuramente qualcosa nella mia vita non
stava proprio andando nel modo
giusto da un lato ogni giorno perpetuava
il rapporto ossessivo con il cibo
dall'altro lato una parte di me prendeva
quell'ossessione e la faceva sua dando
voce alla mia passione alla mia
emozione
e sapete a che cosa ha portato cercare
di riavvicinarmi al cibo sia nel
mangiarlo che nel
cucinarlo Beh ho iniziato a sviscerare
ogni
ingrediente da buona designer curiosa
come sono non potevo che pormi
tantissime domande Come'è
fatto da dove
viene come è prodotto lungo tutta la sua
filiera produttiva chi lo produce e che
impatto ha sul mondo e su noi stessi
è così che mi sono sempre di più
avvicinata al regno dei vegetali della
natura e della cucina
vegetale per intenderci questa sono
io e questo è il mondo al quale mi sono
avvicinata e non solo ho scoperto quanto
ricco sia il regno vegetale ma
soprattutto ho scoperto che un ent aione
a prevalenza vegetale ha un minore
impatto sul pianeta rispetto a qualsiasi
altra e non sono io che lo dico ci sono
studi che lo dimostrano anche se molti
preferiscono ancora non
ascoltare perché la sostenibilità ci
sembra un qualcosa di distante al quale
non possiamo prendere parte ci sentiamo
impotenti ed è vero ma c'è una cosa che
possiamo fare ogni giorno una cosa
c'è scegliere che cosa mettiamo nel
piatto perché scegliere che cosa
mangiare è anche un atto
politico andare al
supermercato
scegliere acquistare e
consumare questo significa aumentare la
propria
consapevolezza ma
aumentare la propria consapevolezza non
è
solo sul Che cos'è
sull'ambiente siamo o non siamo parte
dello stesso
ecosistema non è solo che
cos'è ma anche che cosa mi
va che cosa ci
va
e per spiegarvi meglio questo concetto
Vi propongo un esercizio che a me ha
aiutato e aiuta tantissimo il minuto di
silenzio quando vi state da accingere a
mangiare che sia un pasto preparato da
voi oppure acquistato
altrove fermatevi
Guardate il piatto fermatevi per un
minuto Vi sembrerà difficilissimo che
starete perdendo il vostro tempo ma
fidatevi di me fermatevi
Guardate il
piatto
Respirate lasciatevi andare prima con
gli occhi vedere i suoi colori le sue
forme sentite il suo profumo
fermatevi per un minuto e lasciatevi
andare prima con gli occhi poi con la
mente ed infine con le vostre emozioni
abbandonandovi ai vostri ricordi
va verso il
mondo e torna a noi
stessi possiamo imparare a guardare al
cibo in modo
diverso proprio come ha fatto Munari per
l'arancia Ma possiamo anche
imparare a sentire il cibo in modo
diverso
perché la sostenibilità in cucina è sì
ambientale e
personale ma soprattutto è
personale
[Applauso]
Grazie
n